hello my name is reto Meier welcome to
this week in Android development on
Monday or was 26 2013 last week Daniel
showed us how to drag and rearrange list
view items and you learned how easy it
is to make your apps work well on large
screen displays I used strained
metaphors to introduce a series of
devbytes on making your app transfers
more efficient by understanding the cell
radio the Android design in action team
were added again with their highlight of
beautiful design for summer 2013 and a
roundup of the best seasonal chance our
games team knows how to have a good time
and did so on game on introducing the
joy and wonder of OpenGL ES 3.0 this
week I am going to be here hosting these
we've used some magical boxes to record
this update ahead of time just in case
something dramatic happened over the
weekend let me be the first to welcome
our new insect alien or cyborg overlords
those same magic boxes made it possible
for us to film the next episode of
efficient data transfers early and
playback some tips for analyzing your
transfer profile so even if the robot
apocalypse happens this devbyte will be
available to watch from the shelter of
your bunker Daniel is also back with
another death by at this time looking at
how to work with sliding fragments in
your releases real racing 3 has been
updated to include full Google+
integration that's all for this week in
Android development be sure to check out
this week's def bites and remember that
there will be no sleep til Brooklyn